[موسيقى]
اعتقد والدي منذ
البداية أن كل طفل يتمتع بصحة جيدة هو
عبقري محتمل وأراد أن
يثبت أنه يريد خلق
البيئة كما لو كان صبيًا
ثم اعتقد أنه يمكننا الوصول
إلى الحد الأقصى على الأقل  بنفس طريقة أه
لو كنا أولادًا لأنه في الشطرنج
هناك فجوة كبيرة جدًا
بين أفضل
لاعبة وأفضل لاعب ،
لذلك أراد أيضًا إثبات ذلك من
خلال القيام بالشيء الصحيح بإجراء
الدورات التدريبية الصحيحة
النهج
الصحيح وأعتقد أن هذا كان من
أكثر الأشياء الرائعة التي
لم يقيدها والداي ، لقد قالا حقًا
أنه يمكنك بذل أقصى ما يمكن ولكن
عليك العمل من أجله
[موسيقى]
تعرضت أنا وعائلتي للهجوم
والانتقاد  المرات التي اختارها
والداي لي أنني
أصبح بطلاً أو لاعب
شطرنج محترف
ولا أعرف ما كنت سأكون عليه
لولا ذلك ولكني أعرف شيئًا واحدًا أن
الظروف التي عشناها  في ظروف متواضعة جدًا ،
أنا متأكد تمامًا من
أنني لن أصل أبدًا إلى أعلى مستوى
حتى قريبًا
من المستوى الذي وصلت إليه إذا لم
أكن متخصصًا ولن أقضي
ساعات عديدة من
اليوم وبعد ذلك ساعات أكثر  من خلال
التدرب والتنافس والذهاب إلى
المسابقات
[الموسيقى] في
الواقع ، يحب الكثير من لاعبي الشطرنج
لعب تنس الطاولة كما أعرفها الآن
في سن الثانية عشرة كنت أمارس تنس الطاولة
يوميًا إلى حد كبير كنت أتدرب
مثل ساعتين كان ذلك  جزء من التحضير للشطرنج
وكنت حتى ألعب في
البطولة المجرية في فئتي
العمرية وكان هذا جزءًا من
التحضير لبعض الرياضة
[الموسيقى]
لذا
أعتقد
أن ما يمكن فعله في المستقبل هو
مجرد عقلية الوالدين
لديهم نفس
الأهداف
والغايات بالنسبة للفتاة ، وإذا
أرادت الفتاة أن تكون محترفة ، فلا
تخبر الفتاة ،
دعنا نقول أن هناك فتاة تبلغ من العمر
سبع سنوات تبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات وهي نفس
الموهبة
إذن  على الأرجح سيكون المدرب
س  تحكي للفتاة
أنه يمكنك أن تكوني
بطلة العالم للسيدات للفتى
سيقولون أنه يمكنك الحصول على ماغنوس كارلسن
لذلك هناك فرق كبير
لأنه في الواقع مثل الفتاة التي تقول أنه
يمكنك الحصول على درجة الدكتوراه لصبي مثلك
ستفوز بجائزة نوبل ، لذا
أعتقد أن العقلية يجب أن تغير
المجتمع يجب أن تتعامل بشكل
مختلف تمامًا مع الفتيات وستستغرق
فترة طويلة حتى
تتحسن وتوازن
[موسيقى]